my name is Bob Curley and we're gonna
cover and quite a bit this morning so
first off how many people are using
graph QL in production in the room few
hands cool maybe other people who just
had a play nice what we'll do for the
first 15 or 20 minutes of this talk is
just get a rough grounding in the basis
of graph QL from there what we're gonna
do is move beyond request response type
architectures then move to push based so
how do we get real-time data
interactions with the server and the
client what we're going to do there is a
video Tale of Two Cities we're gonna see
what it actually takes to do that on the
server side and then on the client as
well and finally with a lot of these
data intensive systems it's how do we
actually tune them how do we make them
performance so we'll then look at a
number of tips and tricks to actually
get the most out of these when you go to
implement them as well so a little bit
about myself
my name is Rob Crowley I am a principal
consultant at ratify previous to that I
was the tech lead for api's and
authentication of Bank West for a number
of years so the best amount of my
experience is our distributed systems
design and architecture and to be honest
I'm a bit of an architecture tragic
I'm also the co-organizers of DD deep
earth which is Western Australia's
largest IT conference and I'm also
available on the socials on the right
confession I absolutely love graph QL
but I also love arrests so this isn't
gonna be a talk where I'm bagging out
rest we're gonna try to be quite
objective and as we come across certain
scenarios we're actually going to
highlight well maybe some things are
actually easier in a rest-based
architecture and that's some of the
things that we have to apply to
graphically well to get the same sort of
characteristics so also love arrest and
I'm absolutely fine with that so when we
build api's today what we're really
building is products for other
developers so developers being our
consumers and developing api's today is
what a complicated landscape with many
different types of clients that interact
with our data we've got voice which is
just emerging
od interfaces we have 1d interfaces with
chat and text with traditional 2d
interfaces what web and we also have
emerging a or and v-- or hololens apps
as well and each one of these clients
demands very different amounts of data
from our systems there are different
types of the different manners so the
challenge process of building a
compelling API experience today is far
more complicated than even a couple of
years ago and so the question arises how
can we efficiently send the data that
each one of these clients needs so do we
have single purpose endpoints like what
we might do in rest and just every
client gets the same data but that could
be incredibly wasteful so what we can do
from there is we're always trading off
so do we send too much data to the
client
well that's wasteful again or do we send
too little and then force them to make
repeated calls so typically like a hyper
media driven flow with the REST API
that's an example of under fetching but
what we really want to do is not just
efficiently send the data to the client
we want to send exactly the data that
each client needs in one round-trip to
the server that's what success looks
like in this and what we're gonna do is
we're gonna take a quick look at graph
QL in action though and I don't think
there's any better way to can I get an
understanding of how it hangs together
than just test that issuing you a few
queries to it so what I've just opened
up here is graphical playground so if
anyone's played with graphical it's a
very similar idea so this is just an
updated version from prism which has
support for some of the real-time
capabilities which we'll look at as well
so you can really think of this as an
IDE for graph QL where you could start
composing queries so what we're going to
start from the left hand side is a very
very simple query where we're just gonna
return a little bit of data about a film
and and our domain today is pretty
typical so we're gonna have films we've
got have actors and actors that appear
in certain films as well but what we've
just got to say
I'm requesting a film with the idea of
to the title and the description and
that's pretty damn basic right now but
you can you can already see sobbing
they're sort of flavor for it so in
graph QL what we have with denotes
between these curly brackets is called a
selection set and then each one of the
Isis within it I called a field and
you'll also see that the shape of the
data which I get on the right hand side
mirrors that of the query on the left
and of course you're in the room
thinking I could just do that with a
RESTful API already so let's keep
digging so right now we're then gonna
say okay well let me look at the cast
for today so I want to see a little bit
more about the actors that have appeared
in this movie and from here we can say
okay for this particular actor get me
the actor's name so right now I could
still see in one query I can get not
only top level details about the film
but I could start getting a list of all
the actors within that and likewise I
might say from there is I'd actually
like to know what Paris that actor
played so again I can just go in and
just arbitrarily build up these queries
on the left but as I go through as well
I might then say well for each one of
these actors maybe I want to get all of
the movies that they entered appear did
so in this case now I've just
arbitrarily built that so now I'm having
not only the film details but for each
one of the actors that appeared as that
the role they were cast at and any other
films that they were casted or period as
well so what you could see is we have a
complete inversion of responsibilities
here with a RESTful API we declare
inputs that define how our consumers
interact with our api's with graph QL
all of that power goes to the client so
that that super defines the shape of the
data that it requires and then the
server infers that and then queries that
data but you'll also see as I go through
that graphical or playground seems to
know what a valid field is so I'm not
just typing in randomly this does this
type-ahead so some people in the room
there are probably starting to think
there's some sort of schema involved
here it's defied strongly typed and
you're absolutely right that's the
fundamental or one of the fundamental
building blocks of graph QL and likewise
what we could do from here is we can
actually do a little bit more complex
queries as well so in this particular
case we here's an example of alva search
web I'm not just looking for one
particular type I'm actually then saying
if it's a fill return this sort of data
if it's a John return this type of data
so again we're using this concept here
denoted by the three dots looks quite
like a spread in JavaScript it's exactly
the same concept but what we're going to
do here is when we execute this query
we're then seeing that I get different
return sets based on each one of the
components on the right so this is using
a feature called unions in graph QL it's
not vital to get that concept but what
you can what you can start seeing up now
is this is an incredibly rich and
powerful query language that you can
start doing really amazing things to
pull out
bits of data for each client experience
so there is a schema the fundamental
building block of a graph QL API are its
types and this is an example type remote
domain and this is defined in a notation
called SDL or schema definition language
and what you can see from here is that
there's again a number of properties on
it there's an ID and it has type ID so I
paid identifier typically rendered as
string and it has an exclamation mark on
the right hand side that basically means
it's required or not inaudible such that
if the client requests this field it
will either be guaranteed to have a
value or the server will throw an error
so you can make an assumption that as
parent of the contract you will always
get a value or an error the next field
down its type string so that's another
primitive in graph QL there's also
floats boolean x' a number of others you
can also create your own scalar types if
you wanted as well so you might have an
example of a date you might want to
represent that as an ISO 8601 date so
absolutely you can take that string and
then apply those formatting rules to it
a little bit more interesting as this is
this appeared in so the square brackets
denote a collection but this is another
custom object within our schema or a
domain so what you can now see is this
is how we actually linked our types
together so once I couldn't navigate in
the query I could go from this the film
and then go down to the actors this is
how we define it in our schema and then
again network that's just an example of
another custom object with it there but
again it doesn't have an exclamation
mark on the right hand side so the
client may get a value or may get a dull
and the convention in graph key well if
you are they don't have permission to
see a field of there's not a value you
will get a dull and then it gets each
one of these fields we then associate an
arbitrary piece of code called a
resolver so up at the the root level of
the query which we would have seen in
the example before we have this piece of
code and it's gonna take in a number of
parameters in this case there's
a root value there's any arguments that
get passed into it
there's context objects so anything you
want to associate it with the pipeline
of that request and then there's also a
fourth argument which we'll cover a
little bit later for some other
scenarios as well but all we're doing
here is graph QL is absolutely agnostic
of the data source I don't want to move
so what we can do here is it could be a
database it could be another another
service it could be an mq p topic it
could be anything
graph QL does not care and then against
each field on those types we then
associate another resolver so in this
particular case we're gonna say the
title field on the film object basically
it's gonna take a film object in and
it's just gonna extract that title field
and then pass it back so what we're
gonna look at now I know its first thing
on a Friday so I do apologize but we're
going to cover the absolute minimum we
need to know to have to land in a
vocabulary that's suitable for kind of
discussing some of the concepts in graph
QL so first of all we have this concept
of a tree and the egalité among you
might say this really represents the
query that we had on the left-hand side
so you can really think of a query as a
tree structure where each of the nodes
in the field will either resolve to
another type or be a leaf node and
respond to a primitive data type and we
know the query is complete what each one
of the leaf nodes are pointing at a
basic field for instance like title in
film and what that query is then
projects onto the a portion of object
graph so we really think to engraft you
well to move away from thinking in terms
of like relations that we would in a
database but rather project a viewer
data as a set of interrelated nodes or
graph and what we could actually see
from here in this example is we have a
couple of types of objects we have films
of actors and for any item that appears
within a graph this is referred to as a
node and then the relationship between
two nodes is called an edge and you
might have seen in the queries that I
was typing it had edges and nodes in
there and that's where the language came
from and I'll explain why we model our
schemas like that in a moment and then
for each one of the edges between them
we can then associate particular
information so in this case we can see
each one of the films is connected by a
franchise relation and again if you've
been playing with graph QL for some time
you might have also heard the word
connection and a connection is a group
of edges related to a certain piece of
metadata so for instance for a film
franchise connection for this film would
return all of these edges to its
connected neighbors okay so let's see
how that I will actually work in
practice so once graph QL receives a
query from the client how do we actually
start processing it on the server so
first off we will have a query resolver
so this will take the ID of two and it
will then execute any arbitrary piece of
code that we define to return that
object what it's then gonna do is it's
gonna pass the result of that off to the
resolvers on the film object so the
query we'll know how to return or how to
retrieve a film from the underlying data
store but not how to format it back to
the client so what then does is it calls
another resolver and this was over will
then return title but then also
characters and again that resolver would
then return the characters for that
associated with their film but again it
doesn't know how to retrieve names and
actors so again that resolver will call
the resolver Zod the characters object I
returned name and actors absolutely the
same when it comes down to the actors
object which will then return the name
property at at this point we have
traversed down to the last leaf node in
our query such that we know we are
completed with a package of the
responses send it to the server so what
I hope you can see though is that
there's absolutely no magic with graph
QL at all even though it's incredibly
powerful and flexible for the
client it actually gets executed in
quite a simple manner on the server so
wrapping up that gradual query language
for your API it allows us to craft
strongly typed queries so we actually
know a compile-time whether a query is
valid or not so you won't have any
mismatches at runtime the massively
powerful thing with it particularly have
to support multiple clients with very
different data needs is that it
facilitates retrieving exactly the data
you require and it also has powerful
features such as introspection so you
can actually query the schema itself to
see what a valid type is and we've
already seen an example of that with in
graphical / playground where we could
actually retrieve the valid fields for a
type so this is incredible as well
because it opens up a whole host of
possibilities around well if you already
know the shape of your query why can't
you co generate a view model for that as
well so there's a lot of really powerful
things so on the whole I do think it's
pretty cool but request/response only
gets us so far so why do we need
real-time in a lot of our applications
we simply send a request wait for the
response but think about what we do
today we have a whole bunch of real
world examples as well so we have 1d
interfaces so chat BOTS as well that's
inherently bi-directional we want to
send data but we also retrieve data we
wanted to feel live we want us build
snappy we want to have push
notifications and a whole bunch of other
dynamic data coming through so really a
lot of the experiences that we build
today our customers already expect
real-time interactions with the server
and we need to catch up with how we're
building our API so typically we might
have done that through signal or before
or another approach and again in the
banking scenario so I'm with comm Bank
so whenever my pay goes into my account
this is wonderful push notification to
say I'm now rich again comparatively and
I can go
that's absolutely amazing so again I
don't have to request that data it's
just again that value add that the
servic and then say here's this
information that's valid so again if you
have other examples like stock market
trackers as well you don't got to have a
certain example there where you know you
query at the page is stale again any
updates you have a push back to the
client so what options or approaches do
we have for supporting real-time
experiences in graph QL well a pretty
much mainstay to date across any of
these experiences is polling simply we
will just have the client asset
intervals ask the server the same
question as the server the same question
and this is actually not a bad approach
in a couple of circumstances so if the
data refresh trace is known in so far as
an example from a banking domain the
product rates will get updated once per
day so that's absolutely fine literally
from there call it once per day call it
the same time tomorrow that's absolutely
fine if that cadence was then once every
hour that's still fine because it's
known if you don't know what the update
rate is non-deterministic then you have
to balance freshness with chattiness so
are you willing for the data to be a
little bit stale or do you risk sending
quite a lot of traffic across the
network
another approach that's been talked
about quite a bit in the graphical space
is that of live queries so a live query
you can really think of it as infinitely
fast polling from the client so you
would send a query to the server and if
anything happens to any of the fields
that you requested you just want to get
an updated version and what we could do
for that is the clients can denote that
they want a live query by putting on
this declarative marker on the right
hand side but what it sounds like a very
attractive option it's awesome for
consumers so basically from there you
just anything changes send the data back
to us it is absolutely a nightmare for
the provider side though to try to scale
this
build-it effectively any of the
resolvers change trying to identify that
particular scenarios and push data back
to the client so there's really only a
few companies that I'm aware of who have
actually now built live queries for
Facebook was obviously one and a number
of others as well but this is a not
actually part of the formal spec as yet
you don't got a lot of support for this
out of the box so over the last year the
community has mainly landed on a
different approach and that's called
subscriptions so subscriptions are based
on events so whereas with
request/response so in a query like we
saw earlier there was one query and you
get one response what we're doing with a
subscription is registering our interest
in zero or more occurrences of some
event at some point in the future so we
don't get a response back instantly but
we will get it back potentially at some
point in the future so to be clear these
are really powerful they're not a
replacement for queries but as you'll
see when used appropriately they can
really give that liveness to the
interactions with our users but there's
actually quite a bit of plumbing that
needs to go into supporting these so on
the left hand side we would have the
typical pipeline we would have four
mutations and queries so request comes
in it will then go down to your graph QL
server which will then delegate through
its resolvers down to a business domain
so that can either run in process or
cross process graph QL doesn't care but
of course now if we're going to have
persistent connections with the client
we have to introduce Stace
and typically in graph QL this is done
through WebSockets so that's the
bi-directional transport well we also
introduce is this subscription manager
that will then hold all of the
subscriptions that have been requested
by the clients the subscription manager
will also interrogate the subscription
type on each one of the graph QL schemas
and then keep a mapping between the two
so all that happen is your business
domain can raise an event
that might be an example of payment
received or any other business
development that's your typical in the
area what you work and then the
subscription manager will listen for an
occurrence of that based on that
subscription then call in to graph QL to
retrieve the requested data and then
stream that back to the client so let's
look at an example so we might have a
user and the user will connect to the
subscriptions end point on the graph QL
a peon so you'll notice here that this
is WS is the protocol so WebSockets of
course you can use W SS as well if you
just wanted it authenticated in
production and that's the stateful
connection between the user and the
server so what they can then do is
subscribe to an advertised event so in
this particular case the server exposes
a review added subscription and the
client then for the structure says when
this particular event happens I want to
retrieve the review and I before that
review I want to retrieve the rating
item but I also want to grab the film
title as well and then what could happen
is another user can come into the system
and add that particular review and what
will then happen that's the event that's
being fired and then you will see that
the server will then push that
notification directly back to the client
the client didn't have to do anything
else the data just gets pushed back to
it so let's take a quick look at that
so again I'm getting type-ahead here so
we're going to say review added and in
this particular case I'll grab the
review and in this particular case again
I just want the content of that review
and this time when I click play what I'm
having is we're at the point now where
the WebSocket connection is live between
these two servers going back over to
adding a review then what we can now see
is the first one of those events has
been pushed and appears on the stream on
the right hand side and you can see down
the end that we're still listening so if
we were then to create additional
reviews that data will keep being pushed
as a stream back to the client
the most powerful thing about graph QL
subscriptions is the fact that they
provide a consistent interface typically
with advanced driven systems you need to
comply with the shape of the event
itself with graph QL each client can
still describe the shape of the data
they want to receive when and the
currents of that event happens that is
incredibly powerful and I have to
confess the first time I saw this I was
I that's a massive game-changer because
what that allows me to do is I can have
my initial query to fill up my page with
the shape of data that I want and then
what I can do is I could then subscribe
for updates to that in the same shape
such that when that data comes through I
can just merge directly on to that page
and refresh it I don't have to do any
massaging or translation from that
domain event back into the view model to
display or by client okay so real time
graph QL you have a number of options
realistically today we're looking at
either polling or subscriptions choose
polling if you know the rate at which
your data will refresh you could avoid a
lot of the additional bi-directional
plumbing you need to support
subscriptions if you do need that live
this through events or have a more ad
hoc data refresh scenario then
subscriptions are massively powerful
best thing about them the consistent
interface across push and pull it's
incredibly powerful graph QL allows you
to support both paradigms seamlessly
through one standard interface so again
if you have any teams at work as well
you don't have to support I'll learn
another approach for dealing with this
so it simplifies the landscape quite a
bit and again massively powerful when
used appropriately so the first thing I
would always look at is can I just make
this a query then will poling be
suitable for what I need if both of
those are no then you start looking at
subscriptions
okay so so far we've been really looking
at graph QL sort of baseline and how we
actually look at it on the server and
support some of these pieces of behavior
what will now look at is a couple of the
options that we have for the client-side
Peris of this story and again coming
back to the fact that api's are really
products for other developers we build
them and we want to have make sure that
the consumption of that is as seamless
as possible and there's this rule of
threes that I really like about api's
and it's the three seconds on the left
is a developer should be able to
understand the purpose of your API in
about three seconds they should be able
to gain access to your API within 30
seconds and they should be able to make
a call to that API within three minutes
that's what you're really looking at as
an excellent onboarding experience for
your API so if you're working internally
at your organization and with internal
developers maybe you have a bit of a
captive audience but again if you put an
api product out there when you're
looking for people to consume your
service then focusing on the developer
experience is absolutely key and
developer experience really comprised
two main parts first of all you have
documentation so again this a test who
can actually people understand what the
purpose of your API is in that three
seconds
and graph your has a very powerful story
around documentation because you have a
fully formed schema you can do really
nice documentation on the back of that
and you actually get a huge amount of
this out of the box as well so if you go
to github v4 API which is based on graph
QL as well you can actually have the
documentation and explore through
graphical and playgrounds as well so you
get this IDE where you can start
interacting with the API very seamlessly
and the other part of developer
experience is then the SDK so if you're
building an API for consumed by other
teams you can often know a lot of your
time has actually spent on building
these system development kits so again
if you support clients that use Java
you'll have one that
the JVM if you have clients that use
dotnet again you'll have one from there
and maybe many other languages as well
by moving to graph QL you'll notice that
you get all of this work done for you
there's all of these clients available
out of the box so again with github x'
example with v3 they had client
libraries for many many different
languages before they don't they don't
need to that work is done by working off
a standard interface with graph QL there
is a huge community around that will
build these clients for you so again
another massive win of graph QL is most
of this equation is solved for you
documentation you get a massive head
start on and there's graph to L
libraries for practically every language
out there now so most of you clients
that I'll be looking at today based on
JavaScript so the reference
implementation of graph QL is based on
JavaScript as well there are
implementations across many different
languages as well I'll show you a link
on the reference slide at the end which
will then point to where you can find
what the appropriate implementation is
for you
but in the JavaScript space literally
the simplest client you could possibly
imagine is graphical request and this is
actually great for scripting and all we
do is again imported write our query and
then it's a one-liner to send it to the
server so if you only need to do really
basic calls from a client then start as
simply as you can so that's a simple end
relay from Facebook is absolutely at the
other end of the continuum so relay is
Facebook's solution for building
data-driven applications with graph QL
but it is massively complicated so the
graphical spec is about this big the
relay spec is about this big so my
advice really from there is unless
performance is absolutely key to your
requirements like it's a fundamental
differentiator for the apps that you're
building I really can see the payoff for
relay
most teams it has all of this pre
compilation phase whereby will then do
fragment aggregation as well so it's
really about optimizing the network
portion which again makes a lot of sense
for Facebook with massive geographically
dispersed users and huge volumes of data
so by all means be aware of it
but I would be surprised if that would
be your default best choice we do need
to be aware of it though
so if you're building a public graph QL
API decide early on whether you're going
to support relay clients because relay
is incredibly opinionated and it will
force a certain shape on your schema so
again any connection to a list of other
objects can't be models they're just a
simple array you have to build these
connection objects and they're actually
quite complicated as well so you have to
it forces you to model edges and nodes
and page information and then explicitly
map each edge as well so there's
actually quite a lot of overhead or
complexity that you need to introduce
into your schema but really only wants
to do pagination with a cursor based
model using connections so therefore you
have to support it so the advice is from
there if you're building a public graph
QL API to be consumed by other people
think strongly about supporting relay
simply otherwise that Europe making
choices or employ choices on your users
that they then can't use that library if
it's for internal use within your
company itself then measure for yourself
in the example codes that I've used here
I have used connections and I'll share
the link for that at the end of the
application but then you can see some of
the helper methods that you get from
graph QL relay as well to help you build
some of the connection objects that the
backward as well but you'll also see
that there's quite a lot of code still
to make that work in the gervais with
space my personal favorite is the Apollo
client so again massively feature full
great great great feature set really
flexible not tied to react it also
supports view member Annie
a number of public libraries as well
it's community driven which I absolutely
love so what we can look at now is a
quick demo app that actually instead of
using playground well actually they and
have a simple react app that will allow
us to do similar functionalities to the
demo that we saw previously okay so
first of all I will apologize for the
horrendous color choices but there we go
is that still clear for everyone at the
back cool so the first thing that were
actually going to do is we go to login
so this is another this is still going
to a graph QL API so that's sending a
mutation so what I've done here is send
that to the to the server and then it's
gonna return with an access token that
I've stored in session storage and then
it allows us to query for again any
director's film's actors characters that
match that particular scenario so in
this case is fraud
for the letter A I will be called
bridging both so again what a classic so
we're getting clicking on this we can
now get the list of reviews for this
particular movie but what I've done on
this page as well is I've also set up a
subscription so this is now listening
for any new reviews that could add it to
this film so I then going back into
playground I can do the same thing as I
did before and create a new subscription
from there and instantly the client has
been pushed with an update here but
we're also seeing that the data has
appeared in this query here so I
actually have two subscriptions on this
page I have a subscriptions object
itself which you can see in the code
here which again has a particular query
so quite simple so it just says for for
anytime but we have this subscription I
want to retrieve the review and some
data about the movie itself and then
going down will see the query component
itself so Apollo client or Apollo react
with the react specific parent the next
number of these components are one for
subscriptions one for mutations and one
for queries and these follow the render
prop pattern so again for each one of
these queries we will then have the
section of data so in this case I'm
getting data and loading as props passed
into my method and all I'm doing from
there is issuing a div with that data
what I'm also saying is I'm Reese absque
reiben to future occurrences of that
event as well
so while I showed you render props there
and I don't kill you with code this will
all be available afterwards so you can
drill through it in your own time and
work through these demos as well but you
can also use higher-order components if
you wanted as well so as with Apollo v1
it shipped with a graph QL hoc so you
can absolutely still use that for
composing functionality if you choose as
well as of release 2.0 they've really
been pushing the the red to prop queries
mutations and subscription components
but again the choice is yours
so use both okay
so performance so you can obviously
imagine if we have a lot of data flying
back and forth between our systems we
can op we can either build quite chatty
or potentially do we have a lot of
visibility in those how those are
performing in production and also you
want to notice how fast is fast enough
so one thing that you will also get
out-of-the-box with graph QL is with
Apollo's with the Apollo server is quite
fine tracing along how long each
resolver takes to execute such that you
can highlight performance bottlenecks
within your system as well but one of
the got use with this is with one
response to the server our response is
constrained by the slowest resolver so
if I have one piece of data that takes a
long time to retrieve the entire
response is delayed that doesn't sound
that great
and in fact in in the rest space with
the advent of HTTP 2 we can now have
streams and server push so what we could
still do is have very fine-grained
resources but then push all of the
related resources with that as well and
that we can have different cached
volatilities for each one of those
resources as well in case appropriately
so again we can decouple ourselves from
the slowest piece of data so how would
we tackle that so Apollo supports in the
alpha release know I'm a deferred
directive so similar that we saw the
live directive before for live queries
this this deferred directive allows us
to
Tate certain parents of our schema and
when we annotate it what it's actually
gonna then be inferred is we're going to
delay sending that response back on the
initial response and then send a patch
later so we can do this either at the
type level itself or individual fields
within that type so again let's see an
example of how that might work so what
we have is the client will send an
initial query to the server and in this
case again quite simple we're retrieving
the title and then back on the reviews
we're also retrieving then all the
reviews for that and the contents you
would have seen in the previous example
that we have a defer directive both at
the review object itself which again
using a graph in the miniature is now a
node in the query and on the content
field itself so what the server will
then do is send back an initial response
without any of the different fields so
in this case you can see that the entire
edges for review connection is no what
the server will then do is process all
of those other requests
and when they when the resolver has
completed pushed a patch using
multi-part HTTP back to the clients Fe
browser doesn't support reading streams
then it will fall back to just standard
blocking response behavior for the query
but what we'll now see is the initial
rating object has been resolved but
content is still no and you'll see that
this has a slightly different format to
the previous response what we have in
the top section is the path so how do we
uniquely identify where in that response
tree this data should go and from here
we have a rating of nine but again
content is still no because we also max
that is being deferred so what will then
have I get what we'll see is that
content has now been appended onto the
path list and we now have the content
field and finally when all the patch has
been returned to the server to the
client then we have all of the data
but this introduces of interesting the
whole conundrum because we just said
earlier that if the field is either
missing or you don't have access to it
you'll retrieve a null
we're now using nulls for pending values
as well so is there ambiguity there how
will the client know well shall I
actually expect data or is there just
nothing there so what we could also have
is another prop that can get passed into
our render prop function and in this
particular time is called loading state
and loading state is the same structure
as the data tree so what I can do here
is I can query for loading state check
the review and then check the content
exists for us if it does then if that
resolves the truth then retrieve that
particular contents we know at that
point that the patch has been received
for the client if it's not then we say
it's still review pending so what we can
now do is determine the city identify
for each one of those different fields
which ones will I receive a value for or
which ones are always going to be dull
so that's a really powerful technique
that are quite simple I think as well
another pretty cool feature that we can
use as well is persistent queries so
another concern that you might have is
that the client sends a lot of data to
the server every time like each one of
these queries as well and that can
result in quite high traffic volumes so
then we could also say well you know
what's the pointer that can we do
something a little bit better with rest
I have this really nice little URL that
can describe that you know the canonical
URL to the resource on the server so
what can we do about this so again in
the graphic UL community and we've
actually then landed on this concept
called persistent queries and what we do
from here is this is an example of the
config in the Apollo server where we
have this configuration about persistent
queries and what we introduce is another
key value store which will then in this
particular case I've chosen Redis but
there's options for medication as well
and again we just link the two so what
will then happen in a scenario where the
client wants to not send the entire
query but just send a hash
so again this is a share two five six
hash that it sends to the server and it
generates this hash space and the query
contents itself and it sends it to the
server
what the server will then do is look at
the key value store and say does a query
exist for this particular hash this is
an example of the very first time that a
query has been introduced and the key
value store says no haven't seen it
before the server will respond with a
validation error at this point the
client will then send the hash but also
the body of the query itself so it's
going to execute that query it's going
to store the query for that hash and
then return the response to the client
so this is a flow that will ever only
happen once for the first time you see
that query on subsequent runs through is
what we'll see is the optimistic request
again from the client goes straight to
the server this time we actually
retrieve the stored query for this we
execute it and we pass it back directly
to the client so what you can see from
here as well
is on the top here I have an example of
the initial request that the server
would send so we're gonna local for
localhost 4000 within the extensions
field of the query and I'm asking for
retrieve the query for this hash and of
course what we see now is that the query
doesn't exist yet so I've got a
persistent query not found so in the
example below what I've actually done is
included the body of the query as well
so in this case it's just a really
simple query just retrieving the type
names but what I can do then is once I
actually persist this once you go back
now to the client up here which is exact
same process as the Apollo client we'll
use what we're then seeing is that the
query gets executed directly so that's
just a concrete example of showing what
the if you unpick what the o'clock what
the Apollo client code does is pretty
much this
and there's benefits of doing this as
well so one of the things that always
worked to me about graph QL is if
treated htdp as a dumb pipe everything
was a post so you didn't get any of the
benefit of of caching or all the other
value that HTTP provides and you could
possibly argue that the more customized
your queries get the less value you will
get from caching . but i think there's
still you know like a lot of improvement
we can make there so a really nice thing
now that we have a very simple structure
anymore hashed query we can now turn all
of those posts to get so on the on the
apollo side it's this logic is held
within the apollo linked persistent
queries module and again quite simple to
set up
so again link is a structure within the
apollo stack it's like a programmable
network layer and you can and then you
can chain multiple links together so in
this purse IX's query link what we're
going this is which is responsible for
the same interaction that I just showed
you with the API calls earlier and then
we just set the property of use get for
our hashed queries and from then on now
all of our queries will then be sent as
gets for the words that I have been
persisted now we can start getting value
from cashing so we have this application
control director for in this case I can
say store for 60 seconds and I can do
this either as the type level itself or
any of the individual fields so you
probably get the initial feeling of
persisted queries can help with just an
initial traffic from the client to the
server but now you're seeing that again
a lot of the investment you might prove
these are made in proxy tools like squid
awareness suddenly start paying off
again boss with great power comes great
responsibility so now that we've given
all of our users this power to craft
whatever queries we love and whatever
queries they if they want what happens
if they do pathological queries are
their malicious or again just queries
that would be horrendously expensive to
execute on the server so you might
notice that we can't
completely avoid this issue if we only
use persistent queries such that we will
know a compile-time all of the valid
queries that could hit our server and we
can actually do performance analysis or
as ahead of time but again that's quite
restrictive and if you've got to have
public consumers of your graph QL API
not really an option so how could we
protect our api's from these queries so
we looked at the structure of a resolver
previously and we looked at the first
three arguments but there's also a
fourth argument that gets passed into it
called info and this represents the
abstract syntax tree for that particular
query so again all of the the fields
that you're going to see so we're
getting that in that example that we
shoulder like traversing out down to the
nodes you get that structure such that
you can interrogate it and that allows
us to do a couple of things so we might
have one control based on purely the
depth of the query and there's a package
for this as well called graph QL depth
limit and what we can then say is for
this particular query I can say only
support queries that have a depth of
less or say three and then it will
traverse through down to the query so at
this stage we're at depth 0 with in that
film objects it so for a depth of one
down review step two and then a grazing
depth tree so any other queries that are
deeper than that you would just say no
reject them and it's pretty brute force
but I can be effective so I wouldn't
start in day one with this so put your
queries in and then see over time what
the maximum depth of one of your queries
is typically the largest I've had is
about eight to nine depth so I set the
depth at a max of ten but you can see
yourself that that will probably vary
based on your debate that the complexity
of the queries that you're crafting a
slightly more nuanced approach then is
this concept of query cost analysis and
what this says is really based on that
all fields don't have the same cost
associated with them in the same way
that we might want to defer the slow to
render fields we might also say that
well that's a more cost of the operation
for the server so again we have a
package called graph QL cost analysis
and what that lets us to do through
another directive associate certain
complexity values with the fields
so in the same way as with reversing
down through that structure to execute
the resolvers what we could also do is
traverse that tree and keep a running
total of the cost of this and then we
could put an average ebuddy let's just
say the max cost is 50 if you've worked
out that it would cost more to resolve
the query than that then you just fail
as a product and this is incredibly
flexible so I've just sent a like a
hard-coded value of two there you can
also define multiplicative values so if
it appears within a collection you can
then say that maybe each value is worth
two times that depending on the depth as
well if you get an exponential growth to
your query see huge amount of
flexibility there so if you're doing a
like building a production graph you
labr
I would strongly encourage you to look
at both of these techniques and
persistent queries if applicable as well
for your use case okay so main takeaways
graph QL supports both synchronous reads
and writes but also real-time
interactions through subscriptions the
magic of this is that it's entirely
through one interface so if you're
working with your teams you don't have
to introduce a new set of techniques or
a new technology to support those
different scenarios so you could
integrate them seamlessly with any of
these things as well we want to keep the
surface area of our API so tight so if
you can use features like persisted
queries absolutely do it it will not
only give you a performance boom but
also tighten up some of the edge cases
or performance cases odd you might see
on the server as well and Apollo client
I'm convinced is the best all-round
client for most of the business
applications that will rise and
absolutely worth your attention so
thanks a million I really appreciate you
making out this morning
so I'll put up a reference slide at the
end this is the demo app from the talk
I'll also tweet out my slides a little
bit later this morning but this covers
both the graph QL client so goes through
subscriptions mutations so any of the
functionality that you've seen before
and then also the service side as well
so we do have about four minutes for for
questions so hi
yeah it's a really good question so so
an example of an example of a mutation
for for anyone else here is this an
example of how I've done login in this
app so again it's just mutation and
we'll take a login input object which I
pass then to query variables and in this
particular case you'll see the password
that's in the code that I would have
just NDC kampf in 2017 I use the same
database from last year's presentation I
do know what year it is and then that
will get minted over on the right hand
side as an access token which they then
just pop in the authorization header but
the question was so when you do
mutations and you're and you're not
retrieving the full object structures
that you would have from a query as well
how does that affect re fetching and
yeah you're absolutely right then you
will have you will have warnings
throughout if you look at the Apollo
tooling again this is a this is another
piece that I would recommend everyone to
look at if your so there's Apollo dev
tools and then you'll see down in the
case structure as well on console your
start seeing all of the objects that I
have in the case from here but you will
start seeing warnings then around reef
etching if those particular properties
or titles you know for any of those
don't exist within those objects
themselves as well so a key structure
from here as well is I always look to
keep the shape consistent across those
queries and if you're doing multiple
queries return like an ID and the type
name as well as such that you can
differentiate within the case itself
hi
yeah you can absolutely have you can
have a recursive structure so like I've
shown in that query as well where you
can go from actors to the films that
they that they appeared in and then back
to films as well but because it's a tree
structure and we will always start at
the root and we only fan out then you
will never have a case where you get an
infinite loop from there because we're
just parsing that the tree straight down
but obviously from there then I was
playing in with like the complexity of
that and the amount of like recursive
structures of the other or the
server-side and complexity of querying
that data one of the things that's a
really powerful part for that is this
concept of data loaders so data loaders
here are a library that you can download
as well for it but what they do is per
require per request batching and caching
so if you looked at some of the queries
that come through even if I'm requesting
the same object let's just say act up
with ID 1 and that appears multiple
times without that graph what we'll do
is data load will actually listen to all
of the requests for that objects but
don't execute them directly actually
execute them on process net tick and
then it will actually send one query
downstream and they're all subsequent
calls will actually retrieve that same
object from the data loader request
cache and then the trick with data
loaders is I pass the main on that
context parameter for each query such
that it then gets refreshed each request
so again it's like prayer request
batching occasion but that helps a huge
amount on reducing bandwidth or
producing calls downstream that's it ok
last question
excellent question okay so the trick
with graph QL is don't push business
logic in graph QL itself so the resolver
layer should be incredibly thin so the
resolver layer itself should just call
down to another business logically
either in process so I wrote a lot of
NPM modules then has that business logic
layer so again in this particular
example I've put them all together
within the same solution but I always
look to build so just in the case of a
film-like one one access point to
retrieve those data from any of the
resolver so this place the only way that
I can retrieve a problem is through this
one function so that's where idea B
business rules go so for let's just say
you had a business rule that you can
only return you can only see your own
record so I think we have an example
here so if I wanted to retrieve a user
object basically the login has to match
the login user as well so you can only
see your own record so the trick is not
putting that in the resolver layer at
all so that's the first step
but then what that allows you to do is
use a function to pin the user feature
called schema stitching so what you can
then do is have separate portions of
your schema modeled a separate graph QL
service and then have a graphic ul
gateway above that which will aggregate
all of those disparate schema fragments
and tie them together to what cohesive
whole so if you're actually querying it
from the client perspective it's
invisible to you but then you've moved
away from having a centralized
architecture to decentralized around
particular functions so again as one of
our clients that we will work yet we
ended up splitting the schema across
Gary's like five or six different so we
had what about products customers yeah
yeah and then we'll have the client that
probably Skiba stitching perspective
then tie that together the trick with
that though is you can still do all of
the linking between objects within the
individual schema fragments themselves
the same as you were before but you want
to keep the amount of code to kind of
glue separate fragments together
pretty pretty minimal so you have to use
to say are these really tightly coupled
like do they live together do they
change together probably stick that in
the same schema fragment because
otherwise you're actually just bolting
in glue code up the top to allow
traversing between it separately these
different sub trees but the feature
you're looking for is schema stitching
there's two main options for you can
either use Gramps which Jason lang Dorf
gave the keynote scruffy us about last
year on so that takes a slightly
different approach that uses data
connectors but same you know same same
outcome different way to get there or
schema stitching which seems to be the
predominant way of doing it though but
again I wouldn't start there like if
you're gonna say stats simple get value
out see how see how you can operate it
then if you've seen that the rate at
which you could change is being
constrained by certain portions of the
schema then look to divided up but in
the same way you would have start
building a Bunco services system add a
word right you've gotta have to
understand well where would make sense
to make logical splits within that
schema and then you know so in other
words you can make an informed decision
at some point in the future okay we're
out of time thank you so much for coming
[Applause]